[Music]
do you do stage stuff I have done one
stand-up set and I [__] hated it did
you I hated it why it just was not the
anxiety I felt of if the next joke is
going to land did not overcome the joy
that I felt from telling the joke you're
not narcissistic enough that's part of
it yeah like I I am way too
um hyper self-aware and like hyper
critical and I can't
I I didn't think of bombing as even a
possibility everyone's like you got a
bomb and you're gonna do okay and I was
like I can't mom yeah I'll kill myself
so I just I did it once I did uh it was
actually cute it was 22 Comics doing a
two minute set on February 22nd of 2022.
wow big thing and I went up there and I
did it and I was like that was cool
thanks yeah that was sick wait what was
it like didn't it yeah um and so I went
up there and I did it and I just told a
joke about how I look like the yellow
Eminem
I would have juggled it that's funny
thanks and then about how me and my dad
are twins and he's uh we're both hard to
look out without makeup on because we're
twins okay that was pretty much the set
and people laughed and I was like
like it wasn't worth it because I was
like stand up is such a an art form and
I have my stand-up idols and I just
don't want to I mean that's like
spitting in the fans of Miles
checking IDs you know I'm just that's a
lot to take on I wasn't ready for it so
you could bring that to stand up though
you're very right yeah you should do
that just stand up it sounds good I
think I think I'm past my Prime for that
you could
you should be the spitting comedian I
could take the torch on that yeah yeah
yeah lead the way that is actually an
uncharted waters for comedians you guys
should get on that you don't do any
material you just get up there you're
like hey
who wants it everyone in the front row
is like everyone's
like FaceTiming my friends for the next
hour literally
literally do the next one so you didn't
get that like the bug no the opposite
yeah yeah it was I was proud of myself
though because I did it and I was like
you know what I did it yeah two minutes
uh someone my manager recorded it and
showed it to me and I was like I don't
need to see it you can just oh it's
horrifying oh awful yeah watching
watching one of your own first sets
horrifying yeah I think that um because
you didn't start well both of y'all
didn't really start the stand-up thing
until you had been online for a while I
was in a stand-up for like two almost
three years before everything it's like
that's why I got into the online stuff
because it wasn't going too well
no I mean I just the gr like La yeah it
wasn't but you're right but um
no in La it's [__] it's so brutal to
try to even get a set off imagine like
sitting at a potluck Mike you might sit
there we used to go to Mike's and we sit
there for literally an hour and a half
we go weeks in a row we'd never get
called [__] though yeah dude that's
Santa Monica one we went there so many
times and we'd never none of us waiting
for our name to get picked and it just
never happened yeah
I got pulled once and I went up at 11
45. [__] off in front of like two people
the bar is being wiped down yeah yeah no
actually holy [__] I'm like this is
stupid as [__] how productive can this
be well it is and it's also like that's
not practice no you know getting up
there and doing it in front of two
people closing [__] it's not practice
that you need to feel comfortable in
front of people and to even know if the
jokes land it also has everything to do
with audience and I just like my
audience is so specific I can't go into
a room of just you know average people
that go to a comedy club yeah which is
like couples and their late 30s I would
say can't do that they're gonna think
I'm funny you're gonna be like what the
[__] she talking about that's what makes
you better when you figure out how to
make them laugh yeah I guess who is your
audience my audience is the girls in the
gays okay the gng the gng and the bass
occasionally hey we got we got crossover
yeah shout out all my lesbians
let me love Noel
they do yeah that's uh from the
beginning it's been that because the
nature of the meme when it went viral it
went viral on gay Twitter and so I was
seeing captions of like me when I ate
ass for the first time
I was like that's part of the reason I
got fired is because one of the videos
someone listed the clip of me trying
kombucha and uh the one that went crazy
viral was me when I tasted [__] for the
first time and I said that's crazy and
then my boss pulled me in and was like
you know about this and I was like damn
that's the one you saw out of all of
them you were like I it wasn't me
posting it with the caption you verbatim
that's what I said it's what come tastes
like Brittany
Wow real mature
I didn't it's not me yeah I didn't do
I've never tasted it
I'm just kidding Nancy Reagan was giving
head you [__] why are you mad at me
I'm a hot blooded Americans yeah yeah
didn't Nancy Reagan have like crazy ass
top wasn't that yeah that looks like a
thing yeah so what the [__] is she mad
about yeah what the hell it was it was a
moment in time like I look that was only
what three years ago too it feels like a
lifetime ago that's wild so so
what is how much longer you think you're
gonna stay in L.A do you think you're
gonna eventually indefinitely like and
definitely Creator because I'm I
realized the longer I stay here is like
everything's here yeah no red carpets
events collabs hell yeah red carpets man
red carpet speaking of witch for [__]
tomorrow what tomorrow no I know I gotta
[__] me my stylus what are you doing
we doing the Globes tomorrow let's go
are you hosts per introducing something
we are the hosts yeah
yeah we made it team how the [__] did
this happen is that a mistake or like
you're here to plant his big old lips on
you Maddie Healy
I'm front row yeah I wasn't invited I'll
get kicked out
all right this one's cold I'm gonna kiss
your [__] face
[Laughter]
you're just going we're just going yeah
we got invited yeah
it is that is I would say that's a
sleigh that is a sleigh yeah
real quick
Santa yeah it's a bad joke it's like
ah [__] I'm I'm off man I got brain
damage
that's the way you said that [__] I know
my family calls us my family
I'm off man I got CTE man my family
calls it Dane brammage Ah that's good
yeah thank you so much so that's a good
like Texas it is apparent thing what's
like a funny what's the funniest I think
phrase or like slaying your parents said
growing up the devil's beating his wife
um what does that mean that's right that
means it's raining when the sun's out
yeah oh and that's real
why so what is it what does it mean
it means the sun's out but it's still
raining I know but what's like the I
would joke
[Music]
why would that cause it to rain when
it's sunny the devil's brain
because what the devil's bringing
Darkness on what is otherwise a
beautiful day oh that would be my
interpretation but wouldn't that okay
but wouldn't that also cause clouds
if you can't see these Engineers they
have no
humor it doesn't make any [__] sense
I never said it did no claimed to why do
Texans call a sun shower the devil
who's the first one to say that you know
I'm really I'm big into you know
the origin yeah what's the study of
etymology etymology yeah
like what did uh did a man come running
into the town he's like the devil this
beats in his wife it's like no Jimmy
it's just raining uh the devil's
prolapsing again this one is hailing
prolapsing on his wife the devil's
prolapsing with his wife that will suck
at his wife's prolapse against the
eclipse
yeah that's still eclipses though he
said
this is the winter solstice cash I
thought you were saying you were docking
prolapse
matter in a wet hand's a good one oh
mattered better than a wet hen yeah he
could eat corn through a pickup
he could eat corn through a picket fans
[Laughter]
he's got [__] up teeth that's what
that means yeah yeah
that's good you can't make a silk purse
out of a sow's ear okay okay oh my my
Aunt Shirley used to say one that was um
if you see somebody with big lips you
know instead of like DSL like dick suck
them up she'd say you could suck to
Chrome off a 57 Chevy I said and surely
I'm eight I don't know what that means
he would still say it means you got dsls
by the way honey that means I'm gonna
make a man very happy
noted he's as drunk as Cooter Brown
okay this feels racist for some reason
she's as happy as a dead pig in the
sunshine
okay
no idea she's got more nerve than
Carter's got liver pills
okay I'm finer than frog hair split four
ways that's weird as hell
weird
that feels like some like New Orleans
VooDoo I like that one 11. good one
that's about as useful as tits on a bull
yeah that feels like a classic oh
catwompus is a good one that thing's all
catawampus you all know what that means
no I mean something's like a skew it's
like it's kind of yeah wonky like
unbalanced catawampus my made me say uh
when someone is a lazy eye you got a cat
a Wampus eye kind of like look like that
all the time it's like I don't know what
you're looking at that's not even clever
it's not it's just dumb
you got a catawampus I just call it lazy
got kicked in the head by a mule that's
all
nice dude